hi everyone I hope you had a good
weekend we're gonna start off today's
class talking about the bake-off that
happened last week so if you don't
remember what you did you evaluated
distributed distributed representations
using word similarity data sets and so
all the similar says have these word
pairs with associated human annotated
similarity scores and your evaluation
measured resistance between the word
pairs and your chosen DSM so here's a
histogram of the scores as you can see
there's like kind of two bumps one on
the lower end went on the higher end
most people were on the higher end so
what Chris did was calculate the
observed over expected scores after
separating all the bake-off entries into
the top scoring teams and to the bottom
scoring teams so on the left here we
have that the words that are like more
likely to appear for top scoring teams
and then over here we have the ones that
are more likely to appear for the ones
and bottoms wearing team so that helps
you get an idea of like what
distinguishes the really good models
from the models so so it seems like
retrofitting on wordnet and using LSA
are common ways to build better models
from this rough analysis okay so our
first-place team is group 80s group 80
here no okay
but yeah group 80 basically stacked pute
PP PP mi t-test retrofitting on wordnet
and an autoencoder
and they got the highest score so good
job for group 80 okay now second place
is
this is person here no okay so what this
person did was it looks like a lot but
it's basically PMI plus retrofitting
with a sub word model and they did
pretty well
third place are you here nope
so they also piled on a bunch of things
PMI t-test LSA retrofitting onward net
and they did pretty well as well okay
now a model that did not work as well
we're going to say who this model
belongs to but it is kind of interesting
how they did like t-test LS a jacquard
so I so they did t-test and LS a
together but I think the thing that made
them kind of suffer a bit more is they
use jacquard as their dysfunction is
cosine so that's like an interesting
detail there so it could be cool just to
see like if we swapped out jacquard with
cosine maybe they wouldn't have scored
so low but it's still an interesting
result so like if you're not doing too
well on your models for these bake-off
it's still interesting to see like how
something that could be very well
motivated still fail and yeah I think
that's all I have any questions yeah
there was like another category for like
took the most effort or real time right
he's the winner for that I wasn't able
to find who was that because it's so
hard to like do you like do you quantify
it by lines of code you know because I
saw a lot of teams who they ran a lot of
tests like they had like ten cells and
like each cell had like a different
experiment and they did like a lot of
hyper parameter tuning and stuff like
that so but it could be there yeah there
are some low scoring teams that put an
effort
I gotta hand this off to the real
professors okay I have a couple of
announcements before we get to our main
events so here they are bake-off - has
begun so that was it there was a post on
Piazza within the last hour or so giving
you details on how to do that so make
sure you take a look at that post big
off - closes on Wednesday so you
definitely want to look at that today or
tomorrow on Friday
we're gonna have a special session to
give you an intro to numpy and pi torch
so the details are there and this
session is going to be recorded on
Wednesday we're gonna have some guests
so Guillaume gentie l don't know how to
pronounce that and Marta who's from Rome
analytics and Marta reticence who is
from Google research are going to be
visiting for a panel discussion on NLU
in industry so we want to encourage you
to attend in person if you can to show
them a good good show of support from
from Stanford and to have lots of good
interaction I think the value of that
session will be greatly enhanced if
there's you know lots of in-person
interaction and if you can come to the
session with specific questions that
you'd like to get some insight into what
is it really like to use NLU techniques
in industry and apply the stuff that
we've been talking about in real-world
applications if you have specific
questions or topics in mind there's a
Piazza post encouraging the to think
about this and you can add your proposed
question as a comment on that Piazza
post and it's pinned it so it's visible
at the top of the list that NLU panel
discussion probably won't take the the
full hour and 15 minutes next time so
we'll use the extra time for coding and
class focusing on homework 3 and
bake-off 3 which is about relation
extraction that's what we're gonna look
at today but having some time in class
for that on Wednesday will be
particularly valuable because you'll
have a little bit less time to prepare
before that homework is due next Monday
so any questions before I go in yes big
off to you have to retrain one more time
if you have a model of it you think it
has that good ways personal thing could
you just like not do that
not sure I got that just make sure that
you're using exactly the right training
data that you did that before okay today
I want to turn to a new topic which is
relation extraction and there's kind of
two big ideas that I want to introduce
you to one is the task of relation
extraction itself and the other is this
idea of distance supervision relation
extraction is an interesting topic for a
bunch of reasons that I'll say more
about in a moment but one of the reasons
that it's an interesting turn for us in
kind of the the narrative that we're
developing is that it's the first time
that we're looking at an NLU task where
the output of the task is a discrete
object rather than a numeric value so
we've just been looking at sentiment
analysis in sentiment analysis the
output is a scalar value it might be
like 1 through 5 or in the ternary task
that we're doing for the homework and
the bake-off it's just minus 1 0 or plus
1 some versions of sentiment analysis
it's just 0 or 1 it's basically binary
classification but in any case it's a
scalar value before that we looked at
vector space models a meaning where the
output is a vector of real values with
relation extraction for the first time
we're going to be looking at a test
where the output is an object in this
case it's a relational triple so it's
like a row in a database essentially so
that's a something new and a couple of
weeks from now we're going to look at
the task of semantic parsing where we go
even further in that direction and we're
looking at outputs which are complete
logical forms so that have real complex
structure to them so relation extraction
is one big idea the other big idea is
distant supervision and this is
interesting because it's a strategy for
breaking the data bottleneck that has
been one of the biggest sort of
obstacles to progress in applying
machine learning methods to to NLP and
NLU the idea of distance supervision
enabled people working on relation
extraction suddenly to be able to use a
hundred times as much data as had ever
been used before for relation extraction
and that enabled vastly greater
statistical power in the in the models
that were trained and I'll explain how
that works in a moment but that was a
big innovation that's applicable not
only to relation extraction but to other
kinds of problems as well
what's interesting is that the
innovation here is not so much a new
kind of model it's not a new neural
architecture or a new loss function or a
new optimization algorithm instead the
innovation is in the kind of supervision
that's used to provide a signal on which
to hillclimb it's also interesting
because the ideas of distant supervision
were developed right here at Stanford so
the idea first came about in this paper
by Ryan snow and colleagues in 2005 Ryan
snow was a PhD student who was advised
by dan jurafsky whom some of you may
know so that idea incubated here in 2005
it was then extended by Mintz at all I
think I have a reference to mints at all
right here in this paper distance
supervision for relation extraction
without labeled data so that was also in
danger offs keys research group and part
of the part of the Stanford NLP group
and then this same strand of work led
eventually to a generalization of the
idea of distance supervision which was
the idea of data programming developed
in Chris Ray's group some of you might
know Chris ray who's also a professor in
the computer science department here and
a package called snork
which implements some of the ideas of
data programming which you can see is
kind of a generalization of of this
basic idea these are all strategies to
break through the limit imposed by
needing supervised manually annotated su
fully supervised data for training so
let me say a little bit about the task
of relation extraction is it is this big
enough for people to read this ok
legible okay so the task of relation
extraction is to extract relational
triples from natural language text and
by a relational triple I mean things
like these examples here so founders
SpaceX Elon Musk has spouse Elon Musk to
Lily O'Reilly worked at Elon Musk Tesla
Motors so each of these expresses a fact
about the real world each of them has
three components there's a relation and
then two entities the entities have
these underscores in here so that
suggests that there are some kind of
unique identifiers of these entities and
I'll say more about that in a moment and
the relation is one of a small number of
predefined relations that were
interested in so why is this interesting
why do we care about this well if we can
accumulate a large collection of these
relational triples that amounts to a
database a database of facts about the
real world building a knowledge base
manually is slow and expensive and
time-consuming but the web or other
large collections of documents are
filled with these kinds of facts already
so if we can figure out a way to extract
these facts automatically from natural
language text we can greatly accelerate
the creation of knowledge bases so why
would you care about that why do we want
to have these large knowledge knowledge
bases it turns out that they're
incredibly useful first because a huge
proportion of human knowledge can be
expressed in this form and second
because there are abundant
commercial applications for knowledge
bases like this for example my current
boss John John Andrea
earlier in his career founded a company
called meta web and was the co-creator
of freebase freebase is a very large it
doesn't actually exist anymore which is
a terrible shame but freebase was a
large community authored knowledgebase
which was essentially a vast collection
of relational triples like this it was
acquired by Google in 2010 and it became
the foundation of Google's knowledge
graph which was used to power a variety
of different knowledge applications
including question-answering and also
the knowledge panels that you sometimes
see on the on the right-hand side of
Google search results it was a really
powerful idea a couple of years later in
I think 2014 Microsoft introduced its
own version of a knowledge graph theirs
was called Satori but it was
fundamentally the same thing it also
matters for Apple in 2017 Apple acquired
a startup called lattice which was
co-founded by Chris Rea from the
Stanford computer science department and
lattices business was also to do
relation extraction from documents from
the web in order to build and extend
knowledge bases that in this case are
helped to are used to help Siri better
answer questions about the world so
there's abundant commercial interest in
building knowledge bases like these
there are also other applications that
might be a little bit less obvious one
is extending word net word net is
basically a knowledge base of lexical
semantics relations so in word net the
role of entities is played by words or
actually sin sets and the relations
between them are things like the
hypernym relation or this
or the antonym relation so you can
formulate the task of adding new stuff
to wordnet as a task that has this form
there's there's lots of stuff that
should be in wordnet but isn't so you
know wordnet doesn't know about things
like like there's categories and
subcategories and sub sub categories of
video games right and wordnet doesn't
know about all those different
categories of video games and the fact
that this one is a sub category of that
one but it would be great to be able to
automatically extend wordnet to have
that kind of knowledge and so I
mentioned that this technique of
distance supervision was introduced by
Ryan snow in 2005 that was actually the
application that he applied it to was
automatically inferring relationships
between word senses by extracting them
from natural language text there are
other applications for example in
biology every year there are thousands
and thousands of biology research papers
published some of them have to do with
gene expression and gene regulation
networks if we can make these if we can
apply these techniques to biology
research papers maybe we can run
relation extraction focused on genes and
gene activations over these thousands of
research papers and extract from it lots
of relationships between different genes
and whether they have activating or
suppressing effects on other genes and
by doing that build a big graph of
relationships between all these
different genes and then somehow that's
I'm not a biologist so I don't know what
you do with that from that point but but
that can be really useful to biologists
who are trying to understand these
complex networks of relationships
between different genes so that gives
you a sense of some of the applications
and why you might be interested in this
task ok so how do we actually do let's
return let's
come back to these examples here we want
to learn some facts about Elon Musk and
we want to extract it from natural
language how can we actually do that one
of the techniques that might might come
to mind first is to just write down some
patterns that express the relations that
we're interested in so for example a
pattern like X is the founder of Y that
seems to express the founder relation so
maybe we can just search a large corpus
for occurrences of that pattern and
extract the XY pairs and add those to
our knowledge base so we might find in a
large corpus a sentence that says Elon
Musk is the founder of SpaceX and we're
like okay great I can add a new triple
to my knowledge base that seems very
straightforward and in fact this
approach was the dominant approach this
sort of the dominant paradigm for
relation extraction for many years like
during the 60s and said 60s and 70s so
in the in the very early days of natural
language understanding people tried to
be slightly more sophisticated by
instead of defining an exact string and
looking for exact matches on that string
defining patterns that could be like
regular expressions to accommodate some
minor variation of things like verb
tense and so on but nevertheless it was
the basic approach but this doesn't get
us very far and the fundamental reason
it doesn't get us very far is that
language is incredibly varied there's
just a million different ways to say the
same thing so look at examples like
these you may also be thinking of Elon
Musk parentheses founder of SpaceX who
started PayPal interesting fact Elon
Musk co-founder of PayPal went on to
establish SpaceX or if space exploration
parentheses SpaceX founded by PayPal
pioneer Elon Musk succeeds blah blah
blah so each of these sentences
expresses the fact that Elon Musk is the
founder of SpaceX but none of these
match the pattern that we proposed X is
the founder of Y nor any other pattern
that would be obvious at the outset
right you wouldn't have an
anticipated any of these exact patterns
and even if you may imagine that you
like create a little bit of flexibility
by making it a regular expression
instead of an exact match there's no way
you would have anticipated any of these
patterns now once you see these examples
you could say okay well I'm gonna create
new patterns I'm gonna add to my pattern
list by having a pattern that captures
you know X parentheses founder of Y and
maybe that will match some more examples
somewhere else in my corpus and then I
can add another pattern which is X comma
co-founder of PayPal went on to
establish Y or maybe I should actually
replace the PayPal with a star so that I
get some more generalization but like
these things aren't really gonna help at
all these patterns are still really
specific they're not going to match that
many if any other examples in your
corpus they're not going to generalize
well to new examples and so the result
of adopting this approach is even if you
manually engineer even if you write down
lots of patterns and you try to make
them general by using regular
expressions you're gonna wind up with a
system which might have high precision
but it's inescapably gonna have very low
recall there's going to be lots and lots
of sentences which express a relation
which don't match any of your patterns
and you're just going to miss those
you're not going to have the opportunity
to do those extractions so that strongly
suggests embracing machine learning and
so this is what happened in the in the
90s and the 2000s there was the
so-called statistical revolution that
came to NLP and people said hey let's
use data and machine learning to learn
the things that we want to learn and in
addition let's use a feature
representation that will allow much
better generalization from the examples
that we have so to do this we're going
to have we're going to need lots and
lots of supervised data to
our model so what we would do is go
through our corpus and every time
there's a sentence that has two entities
in it we would manually annotate it with
the relation if any that holds between
the two entities or if there's no
particular relation then we just say no
relation so we go through and we'd find
this sentence and we'd say Elon Musk and
SpaceX and we'd annotate that with
something that says founder and we'd
annotate the second sentence and the
third sentence with something that says
founder there might also be sentences in
our corpus like this one billionaire
entrepreneur entrepreneur Elon Musk
announced blah blah blah I'll let you
read it it's got both Elon Musk and
SpaceX but it doesn't actually express
the founder relation it's not saying
that Elon is the founder and so we'd
manually annotate this example with a
label that says no relation so now we've
got a big corpus where all pairs of
entity mentions are annotated with a
relation that holds between them or no
relation and we can train a class that
we can define a feature representation
for each of those pairs of entity
mentions maybe it's just the bag of
words in the sentence and then we can
train a classifier using techniques very
much like what we've been exploring for
sentiment analysis and this works it
totally works and it was a huge step
forward for relation extraction it
allowed us to build relationships
raction systems that got much better
performance than the hand-built patterns
that came before and particularly much
better recall than what came before but
it has a big shortcoming as well which
is that it relies on having this
manually annotated data from which to
learn you have to go through a corpus
and and manually label everything and
that manual annotation again is slow and
expensive and it doesn't scale and in
fact when this was the dominant paradigm
in relation extraction during the 90s
and 2000's the largest data sets that
were constructed for relation extraction
had on the order of thousands of
examples
today a dataset with only thousands of
examples seems kind of small and it's
certainly not enough to do to apply
sophisticated modern methods to so the
big innovation that I I want to focus
your attention on and get you excited
about is this idea of distance
supervision so here's the big idea this
is the big conceptual breakthrough we're
gonna sidestep the need to manually
annotate entity mentions in a sentence
by using an external resource as a
source of truth so in particular we're
going to use relational triples from an
existing knowledge base to automatically
identify extraction examples in a big
corpus let's say for example we already
have a knowledge base that contains this
relational triple founders SpaceX Elon
Musk what we do is we take that pair of
entities SpaceX and Elon Musk we search
through a large corpus for any sentence
that contains those two entities and
then we make the unreliable assumption
that that sentence expresses the founder
relation and we effectively label each
entity pair each example in a sentence
with that relation label so it's a way
of using this external data source the
knowledge base to generate labels in the
corpus rather than having to manually
label all of the examples in the corpus
yeah situations where we have both you
on Moscone like-likes SpaceX Elon Musk
and so when we're looking through our
corpus we don't want to assign more than
one label to a sentence absolutely and
we'll come back to that question in a
moment because it goes to how do you
formulate the classification problem is
it a multi-class classification problem
where you have to choose just one
relation out of a bunch of relations or
ism is it a multi-label classification
problem where you can assign as many
labels as you want yes can you only do
this
on something we've already built upon
the knowledge base previously a new
surprise their meditation or like
Annabel features yeah one of the
limitations of this approach is that
because it starts with examples of the
relation that you care about you can't
use it to build a knowledge base for a
completely new relation or add a new
relation to a knowledge base if I want
to learn to do extractions for the
founders relation I need to start with
some examples of the founders relation
if I don't have any examples yet I'll
need to use a different strategy yep
it is say a little bit more
bootstrapping is an overloaded term
basically the same idea if you read you
might have you might be referring to the
reading from jurasky and Martin where
they talk about bootstrapping yeah so
it's basically a way of formalizing that
idea and making a little bit more
rigorous the way the bootstrapping idea
is presented interesting Martin the seed
examples the seed tuples are just chosen
by hands you just kind of think about it
what are some examples of the founder
relation and you come up with a very
small number like maybe a dozen and
start the process from there the other
difference is that the way bootstrapping
is presented by jurasky and Martin it
can be a repeated cycle where you use
the seed tuples to get some extractions
from your or to identify some examples
in your corpus which may help you
identify new patterns those patterns in
turn can help you identify new tuples
and the process can repeat with distant
supervision we're not repeating that
process we start with a much letter much
larger set of seed tuples hopefully if
our you know if our knowledge base is
already kind of large and our goal is to
extend the knowledge base we're starting
with lots of
tuples and we're we're not sort of going
around that cycle repeatedly we're just
doing it once other questions before I
go on say for example like that sentence
could it extract that Elon Musk is both
the founder PayPal and the founder a
co-founder of absolutely so the way the
problem is usually set up every pair of
entities is a candidate for relation
extraction and so if you have three
entities in a sentence there are three
pairs and you can consider each one of
those three pairs and you know if there
are more entities that you have even
more potential pairs and each each one
can be considered yeah so using this
external knowledge base as a source of
supervision that is the central idea of
distance supervision and it's a really
powerful idea and one of the reasons it
was such a game-changer for relation
extraction about 10 years ago is that it
allowed us to suddenly use a hundred
times as much data as had ever been used
before
I mentioned that the largest data sets
that were fully supervised had thousands
of examples but at one stroke this idea
allowed us to allowed mints at all the
authors of the 2009 paper to use a
hundred times as much data by using a
hundred times as much data they were
able to define a feature representation
that had much more precise sort of
specific pinpoint features and they
actually had enough data to overcome the
problem of sparsity for those very
specific precise features and that
enabled them to get much better power
from the from the model that they were
building and in fact like at that time
they were able to achieve a 100x gain I
mean there's no there's nothing in
principle that limits even larger
scaling up
they were constrained by the
computational resources available at
that time
today we could probably easily go to a
thousand times or ten thousand times as
much data as people were using for
relation extraction in the 2000s so it's
been a very successful idea it has two
limitations or two yeah two limitations
one is that it relies on making this
assumption that every sentence where so
I'm starting from this triple in my
knowledge base founders SpaceX Elon Musk
I go to the corpus and I found every
sentence where those two entities
co-occur I'm making the assumption that
every sentence where those two entities
co-occur actually expresses the founder
relation but we know that's not true we
know that's an unreliable assumption
assumption and in fact I just showed an
example of a sentence that doesn't
express the founder relation the distant
supervision approach is going to label
that as an example that does Express the
founder relation that's wrong so by
doing this I'm essentially injecting
noise into my data set and that makes
that creates a challenge for the
learning algorithm it's harder to learn
when you have noisy labels that
disadvantage is more than outweighed by
the benefit of having vastly more data
and so even though you're your learner
has this additional challenge it's still
able to learn much better models the
other limitation of this idea is the one
that was already mentioned it can only
be used to extend an existing knowledge
base or an existing relation but but
because it relies on existing triples
from the database from the knowledge
base it can't be used to create a new
one from whole cloth okay so that's the
the biggest idea if you only got that
from today's session I think you would
have already gotten something valuable
what I want to do with the rest of the
time is to walk you through the rest of
this code book to help prepare you for
looking at homework three and bake-off
three which are going to be due next
week so we have a little bit of setup
stuff we're going to import some useful
classes and libraries and some data so
the data directory for the class
includes a subdirectory called rel xed
data and there's two things in there
there's a corpus and there's a KB and
I'm gonna say a little bit more about
each of those if you have sort of the
default setup then this code should work
for you out of the box if you put the
data directory somewhere else you may
need to fiddle with the line that tells
it where to look for the data okay so
two data asses to talk about the corpus
and the knowledge base as usual when
whenever we're doing NLU we start with a
corpus a large collection of examples of
language and in this case we there are
some specific things that we need from
our corpus we need lots of examples that
contain two entities that's the whole
idea and it's gonna be really useful if
those entities have are already have
what are called entity resolutions so an
entity resolution basically takes an
entity mention like a string in a
sentence that refers to an entity and it
Maps it into a unique unambiguous
identifier and that's gonna be really
useful because we're gonna want to
connect the corpus to the knowledge base
which is going to use the same unique
unambiguous identifiers so making the
identifiers unique and unambiguous kind
of solves two problems one is the
problem of poly semi which means
probably Samia is when one word or one
phrase can mean two different things so
the example here is New York New York
can mean New York State or New York City
if I've done entity resolution correctly
those will map into two different unique
identifiers New York City will have one
identifier New York State will have a
different identifier and hopefully
something in the context around will
tell me which one of those it should map
to so that's poly semi the other problem
that helps to solve is synonymous
when you can have two different
expressions that refer to the same
entity so
New York City and the Big Apple both
refer to New York City hopefully those
two different expressions will both get
mapped to the same unique identifiers
when we do entity resolution entity
resolution is a whole topic unto itself
there's people you know work on
developing models for doing entity
resolution properly that's a topic that
we could unpack in this class but we're
not gonna do that we're gonna kind of
treat it as a black box and assume that
it's already been done correctly and for
this project what we're gonna use for a
corpus is a bunch of examples that are
derived from this wiki links corpus wiki
links was the result of a collaboration
in 2013 between Google and some
researchers at UMass and it's drawn from
a really large snapshot of the internet
10 million web pages altogether what
Google did is they Google has a terrific
entity resolution module in house and
they just ran this entity resolution
system over millions of web pages and
basically recorded the results so the
entity resolutions that appear in the
wiki links corpus are not the result of
human annotation they're the result of a
model that's just running over webpages
and if you wanted to you could build an
entity resolution component from scratch
and then you don't need any annotations
on your data at all you just start from
arbitrary text from the web but to make
lives a little bit easier for ourselves
we're going to leverage the output of
this entity resolution system from
Google through through wiki links
[Music]
there's something else we want which is
that we want to have the context around
the two entity mentions so we'd like to
have the text before the first mention
the text between the first mention and
the second mention and the text after
the second mention because all of that
context is potentially predictive of
what the right
relation is if you look back at some of
the examples that I gave like in the
first example Elon Musk founder of
SpaceX well there's something in the
middle here the word founder that's
strongly predictive of the right
relation the in the second example
you've got this word established that's
in the middle which is strongly
predictive well I thought I had an
example where at least intuitively the
most predictive thing is not in the
middle but is outside maybe that example
comes later
anyway we want to have that context
around the around the to enter
dimensions and the umass version of the
wiki links data set actually has that
context so to help set things up to be
convenient for for the purposes of this
class we massage the data we filtered
the data to make it small enough to
easily load into memory and to work with
but what we wind up with is a compact
corpus that's going to work really well
for our purposes there's a corpus class
that provides some easy access methods
to some of this to the contents of the
corpus so I want to give you a peek of
some of that and at the same time do
some some data exploration so to load
the corpus into memory we just use this
call here and we can start to poke
around and see what we're working with
so the corpus has examples every example
is two entity mentions in the context of
a sentence there are three hundred and
thirty two thousand examples so that's
great that's plenty of examples but
still small enough to easily work with
in memory let's take a look at what an
example looks like so we'll just look at
the first example here this is
horizontally scrolling so it's a little
hard to read but each example is
basically a tuple and it has if I
remember correctly twelve fields
so the first two fields are called
entity one and entity two so in this
example entity one is New Mexico and
entity two is Arizona these these are
the unique identifiers for entities that
I mentioned the fact that New Mexico has
an underscore in it kind of suggests
that this is not just an English
expression this is actually a unique
identifier in some kind of entity space
and in particular these are so-called
wiki IDs so this is basically a the last
part of the the URL for the Wikipedia
page corresponding to this thing and
serves as a unique identifier for New
Mexico and for Arizona in this case then
the next five fields are fragments of
the text from this example we have a
field called Left which is all the text
to the left of the first entity mention
then we have mention 1 which is the
English text
so here it's New Mexico without the
underscore because this is the actual
fragment of text then we have the middle
which is everything between the two
mentions in this case it's just and then
we have mentioned to Arizona and then we
have right which is everything to the
right of the second mention and so if
you pasted those together you can kind
of get the the whole sentence the
procedure is still used in parts of New
Mexico and Arizona is to build a fire
inside the horn oh and so forth
and then the last five fields are
similar to the previous five fields
except that they have part of speech
annotations so every word has a slash
after it and following the slash is
something in all caps to DT JJ n NS d t
NN and so forth that indicates the part
of speech of that particular word and
again the parts of speech have been
generated by an automated system by a
model you don't need to worry too much
about the meaning of the different parts
of speech they come from the penn
treebank
annotation scheme there's about 40 or 50
different categories you can sort of
figure out what they mean n n means noun
n n s means plural noun things like that
but you probably don't need to worry too
much about what the specific things mean
the reason they're here is that they
could be useful in building feature
representations for your model and you
may find in fact I think one of the
homework questions asks you to try to
leverage the the parts of speech
information to get better better
generalization capability oh and here's
a code fragment which actually pastes
the left mention one middle mentioned
two and right all together to sort of
reconstruct the original sentence let's
do a little bit more data exploration
just to get a better sense of what's in
this corpus and by the way this is good
method law methodological practice
whenever you start working with a new
data resource do some poking around and
figure out what's in there try to try to
look at some summary statistics of what
the data looks like we wrote a little
bit of code to extract all the entity
mentions and then count them up and so
here's a list of all the entities by
frequency there's a lot of geography
things in fact looking at this list you
might think that it was only geography
that's not actually the case
but it certainly looks that way right
here one of the benefits of having a
corpus class is that it makes it we can
do some indexing and make it easy to
retrieve examples having specific
characteristics so in particular there's
a method called show examples for pair
that makes it really easy to look up all
the examples that contain a particular
pair of entities so here we looked up
the examples that contain Elon Musk and
Tesla Motors and the output tells us
there's five examples like that and it
prints out the first of those five
examples but actually Direction matters
here so this isn't necessarily all of
the examples that contain Elon Musk and
Tesla it's just the examples that have
Elon Musk as entity one and Tesla as
entity two
it could be the other way around so
let's also look at show examples for
pair Tesla Motors and Elon Musk and it
turns out that there's two more examples
that have it the other way around so we
need to be conscious of direction if we
are looking for examples that have Elon
Musk and Tesla Motors we need to check
in both directions when we're making
those calls this corpus does have some
flaws one flaw that you'll discover as
you get further into things and start
poking around more is that there are
lots of examples that are near
duplicates of each other so not exactly
the same but with minor variations like
only a few words different or something
like that I think this is a consequence
so this come this is this comes from the
wiki links data set and I think this is
a consequence of the sampling strategy
that was used to choose the 10 million
web pages from which the data set was
constructed I don't know all of it I
don't know exactly how they did that but
there's lots of near duplicate documents
on the web pages that differ from each
other only by a little bit and I think
they didn't try to weed those out and so
you will see lots of those near
duplicates and they will cause some
funny looking results that will run into
later it's a flaw but it's not a
showstopper for this data set the other
observation to make here is that this
corpus doesn't contain any information
about relations
unlike the supervised paradigm there's
no explicit indication in this corpus
about what relations hold between the
entities there's nothing in this corpus
that tells us nothing except the English
words in this corpus that tells us that
Elon Musk is the founder of Tesla so to
get that we're going to have to connect
the corpus to the knowledge base so
we'll turn our attention to the KB now
before I go on any any more questions
about the corpus yeah
you did feel like there was a factory in
space like that
we did like space and too we could get a
list of words that have both space of
two or their own entities and in this
case it was entities that were
identified as entities in the wiki links
corpus and therefore entities that were
recognized by the entity resolution
system that Google used to generate this
data but that's a possible variation and
in fact earlier I mentioned the work by
snow that was used to extend wordnet and
they had a different notion of like what
were the units of extraction and instead
of entities they were they were looking
much more generally at nouns and trying
or noun phrases and trying to learn
relationships between noun phrases okay
let's turn to the knowledge base now the
knowledge base that we're going to use
is a fragment of freebase I mentioned
freebase earlier it's this large sort of
community constructed knowledge base of
relationships between entities
it was very sadly shut down in 2016 but
you can see if you poke around in the
internet you can still find data dumps
from freebase and the the knowledge base
that we're going to include here was
derived from a freebase data dump so in
freebase you have these relational
triples that we've already looked at
each one consists of a relation a
subject and an object subject and object
that's just kind of there's no
connection to subject an object in a
syntactic sense in the sense of English
syntax it's just kind of an arbitrary
designation for the first argument to
the relation and the second argument to
the relation the relation the thing in
the first position is one of a small
number of predefined relations like
place of birth or has spouse and the
entities that appear in the second and
third position again our wiki IDs so
it's like the last segment of a
Wikipedia URL and it constitutes a
unique identifier that we can connect to
the identifiers used in the corpus just
like we did for the corpus we should do
some data exploration and see what this
data actually looks like so here's a
line of code to load the KB into memory
and then we can start poking around
so there's 46,000 KB triples here that's
great that seems like a fair amount to
work with there's sixteen relations in
this knowledge base Wikipedia freebase
the original fruit like the full
freebase has way more than this so
freebase has thousands of relations
millions of entities and literally
billions of relational triples what
we're working with here is a is a fairly
small slice of that whole knowledge base
then you might want to know how big is
each relation how many triples does each
relation have so we've counted them up
and you see the results here it looks
like the contains relation is the
biggest one it's got 19,000 triples and
some of them are quite small so the
capital relation has only 500 triples so
they vary quite a bit in size here's
some code that prints one example from
each relation just so you get a sense of
what's in here so it joins France Spain
pretty intuitive author uncle Silas
Sheridan lafon new capital Panama Panama
City I think these are pretty intuitive
for the most part one thing to point out
is that some of these relations are
intuitively symmetric relations so I
presume that a joins relation is
symmetric and if joins France Spain is
in the knowledge base then probably
hopefully a joins Spain France is also
in the knowledge base however there are
no guarantees in theory its symmetric
but nothing actually guarantees that the
inverse relation is actually in the
knowledge base other relations are
intuitively asymmetric so author uncle
Silas Sheridan lifts on ooh that's fun
to say it's a bit arbitrary that the
relation was defined in that direction
there's no reason why it couldn't have
been the other way around so it could
have been
author of Sheridan the funny uncle Silas
that would have been fine the
representational choice that was made
here was to put the author first and the
work second and by the way that also
points out that relations frequently are
typically have types so a relation will
have a type for its first argument and a
type for its second argument just like
in the corpus there's a convenience
method that makes it easy to look up the
KB triples that contain a particular
pair of entities so we can look up all
the triples that contain France and
Germany it looks like there's just one
there is a relation adjoins France
Germany oh and we can also look up
Germany and France so it turns out yep
the inverse relation is in there that's
great we can look up the relation
relations between Tesla Motors and Elon
Musk who we get the the result that the
founders relation holds between Tesla in
Elon Musk that's great I kind of said
some of this stuff already oh and then
we can look up things the other way
around we can look up the relation
between Elon Musk and Tesla Motors and
there is a triple worked at Elon Musk
Tesla Motors so that kind of makes sense
and then this point addresses a question
that came up earlier there can be more
than one relation that holds between a
given pair of entities so Cleopatra and
Tommy Lee blah blah blah have both the
has sibling relation and has spouse
relation which seems you know unusual
but I guess things were different back
then and then we can look at the
distribution of entities in the KB so
here we go through all the triples count
up all the entities and list them in
order of frequency and again you see
that it's dominated by entities that are
related to geography and in fact this
list look like let's look like look
like it's only geography but that's not
actually the case one last observation
there's no guarantee that the KB is
complete so this knowledge base has
founders SpaceX Elon Musk
it has founders Tesla Elon Musk it has
worked at Elon Musk Tesla Motors but it
does not have worked at Elon Musk
SpaceX even though he did and given the
other three you would think that it
should but it just so happens it doesn't
and in fact that's the whole reason that
we're doing this the whole reason that
we're doing this is that we want to
extend an existing knowledge base with
facts that should be in there but aren't
if the knowledge base were already
complete we wouldn't have any work to do
so the fact that it's incomplete is no
surprise and in fact it's the whole
motivation for doing this thing okay so
the next question to look at is how are
we going to formulate the prediction
problem that we're going to undertake
and there's really two questions here
one is what's the input to the
prediction problem and the other is
what's the output what's the input means
what is the what is the unit that we're
going to try to make a prediction about
the classic formulation of the relation
extraction problem was to say the input
is a pair of entity mentions in a
specific context in a specific sentence
and for pair of entity mentions in
context we're going to try to predict
the relation that holds between them
there's an alternative which is to say
the unit of prediction the input to the
prediction problem is instead just a
pair of entities not a pair of entity
mentions but just a pair of entities
abstracted away from any specific
context so that's one choice we need to
make the other choice is what's the
output of the prediction and this ties
back to the question that came up
earlier are we trying to predict a
single relation that holds between the
two entities or can we predict multiple
relations to hold between the two
entities like the example of has sibling
and has spouse both holding between one
one pair of people
it's worth noting that the classical
approach to relation extraction chose
the first answer to both of these
questions but today the path that we're
going to pursue chooses the second
answer to both of these questions and
I'll spell that out a little bit more as
we go so we're first going to talk about
the first one how do we how do we
formulate the input to this prediction
problem and that really comes to the
question of how we're going to connect
the the corpus and the KB there's kind
of two possibilities the way I described
it earlier it kind of sounded like we
were going to use the knowledge base as
a way to generate labels on entity
mentions in context and that's similar
to the classical approach to relation
extraction and we could do that but
actually we're going to do something
else instead we're gonna define our
problem as the problem of classifying
not a pair of entity mentions but a pair
of entities and we're going to use all
of the examples from the corpus where
those two entities co-occur to generate
the feature representation for that
classification problem so instead of
trying to classify a mention of Elan and
Tesla in a specific sentence we're going
to take all of the sentences where Elon
and Tesla Co occur and use those to
generate a feature representation which
will help us make a prediction about
whether Elon and Tesla in abstract apart
from any specific context are related to
each other that's a really important
step so let me pause there and let that
sink in and make sure that it makes
sense we're gonna the input to the
prediction problem will be a pair of
entities considered apart from any
specific context but when we generate a
feature representation we're going to
use all of the sentences in the corpus
where those two entities co-occur as the
source
for those features okay so that means
that we need to use the the entity IDs
the the the wiki IDs as the way to join
the corpus and the KB and continuing the
idea of data exploration we can look at
how many examples we have for each
triple so we can go through the triples
in our knowledge base for each one we
look up all the examples in the corpus
that contain those two entities and we
can look at in aggregate or on average
over the over the knowledge base how
many examples we have to support each
triple so this table summarizes that
like for a joins there are 60,000
examples all together but 1,700 triples
and it means there's a lot of examples
for every triple we have about on
average about 34 examples for every
triple that's terrific we have lots of
evidence lots of examples to draw
features from to help us learn an
extraction model for this relation there
are other relations where the number of
examples is much smaller so some of
these have an average number of examples
per triple of like one and a half and
that means we're going to have a lot
less evidence in the corpus to draw on
there's one more thing we need to train
these models and that is negative
examples the the the connecting the the
KB triples two examples in the corpus is
going to give us positive examples for
training our models but but you can't
train a model from positive examples
alone you need negative examples as well
so to get negative examples for each
relation we're basically gonna use pairs
that appear together in the corpus so we
have some evidence for them we have
features for them but pairs of entities
that are unrelated according to the
knowledge base that is they don't appear
together
in any cable in the knowledgebase
so these are pairs of entities that
appear to be unrelated but where we have
sentences that they co-occur and we've
written some code that walks through and
finds all of those unrelated pairs and
here's some examples William Randolph
Hearst the cat's meow Les McCann Bobby
Timmons Chateau eben al-khattab I don't
even know what most these things are but
they appeared together in a sentence
somewhere and yet according to the
knowledgebase they're not related so
we're going to use these as the negative
examples for our classifier okay so that
was all related to the input side of the
prediction problem on the output side we
have this choice to make about whether
we're doing multi-class classification
or multi-label classification and the
direction we're going to go is
multi-label classification and part of
the motivation for that is that it's
actually quite common in the knowledge
base for a particular pair of entities
to belong to more than one relation we
already saw one example the one with
Cleopatra and has has spouse and has
sibling but there's a lot of them and we
can write some code to count them up it
turns out that there are some overlaps
that are really common and they're kind
of intuitive so it's really common for a
pair of entities to belong both to izi
and profession that makes sense so it's
like Einstein is a physicist and his
profession is physicist capital and
contains that makes sense as well place
of birth and place of death there's no
necessary relationship there but in
practice it's quite common for people to
die in the same place they were born so
that's not too surprising when we go
down further there are some that are
surprising has spouse and parents Co
occurs at least once oh this is
interesting has sibling and has spouse
it turns out Cleopatra's not alone
there's at least 7 other cases where
those two overlap there's one case where
we have three relations that overlap
nationality place of birth in place of
death I think that one makes sense
but like this one looks like noise
parents and worked at there's two
examples of those overlapping and I
think that's just some kind of data
error I don't know what happened there
but I think that's noise so we're gonna
formulate our problem as multi-label
classification this means that we can
assign multiple relations to a given
entity pair there's many different ways
to do multi-label classification but the
simplest way to do it is what's called
the binary relevance method and the
binary relevance method basically means
factor your prediction problem into
unrelated binary classification problems
so if you have in this case we have 16
relations right so what we're going to
do is just factor it into 16 separate
binary classification problems for each
relation we're gonna try to predict does
this entity pair belong to the relation
or not it's just a binary classification
for each of the 16 relations there are
smarter ways to do multi-label
classification because this way of doing
it doesn't take account of the fact that
the labels or in this case the relations
can be correlated with each other it
just assumes everything is independent
but it's a very simple way to set things
up and it will work well enough for our
purposes so one way to think about our
prediction problem is for a candidate kb
triple for a specific relation and
entity 1 and entity 2 does it or is it
or is it not a valid kb triple should we
add it to our kb if it's not already
there
that's the binary classification problem
that we're reducing this problem to okay
then there's some code to create
datasets I'm not going to dwell on this
but a data set basically is going to
combine sorry no data set is going to be
a bunch of kb triples along with lait
that say what the correct what the
correct binary classification for that
KB triple is the thing to be aware of is
that because we're factoring our
prediction problem by relation all of
these data structures are going to be
organized into Maps front or
dictionaries from a relation to some
other stuff so we're gonna have these
things where it says KB T's by rel that
basically means a collection of KB
triples that have been grouped by
relation so the data structure is a
dictionary where the key is a relation
name and the value is a list of KB T's
there will be a list of KB T's for this
relation and a list of ABT's for that
relation and so on that's this first
thing here the second thing here is an
exactly parallel data structure that has
the labels for each KB T it's gonna say
whether that thing should have a true or
a false prediction made for it and this
method here build data set is going to
combine positive and negative data it's
going to run derive the positive data
from the KB and it's going to derive the
negative data in the the way I described
by looking for pairs of entities that
co-occur in the corpus but don't Co
occur in the knowledge base it'll
include both positive and negative data
there's a parameter that lets you
control the sampling rate the default
sampling rate is zero point one because
we have about 10 times as much negative
data as we do positive data so using
this sampling rate sampling rate will
give you a roughly balanced data set and
it also lets you specify a random seed
so that you can have reproducible
results if you want yeah I guess
confused
I'm not sure if I understand the
question are you talking about words
that you might use in the feature
representation as predictors yes so like
I'm just singing like I guess you can
tell me whether or not this is
initiative when I think of sorting these
triplets violation I can see the word
play as being used for either playing an
instrument or playing a sport these are
very different things
yeah and so a is not a problem I guess
and then B if that is a problem have you
I guess counter that I so I think you're
asking about the the words that you
would use to try the the the way you
construct a feature representation to
try to make a prediction and do you need
to account for ambiguity do you need to
resolve ambiguities like that one in
constructing the feature representation
that's something interesting you could
play with I think the typical answer is
no we don't typically try to do word
sense disambiguation before constructing
a feature representation but it's
possible that could yield some benefits
play is a relation that appears in your
in your KB okay I miss that yeah the the
knowledge base should if it's if it's a
well constructed knowledge base it
should resolve those ambiguities part of
what we're aiming for with the knowledge
base is that it's completely unambiguous
that it that I I kind of spoke about
this a little bit earlier
in connection with the entities that
when we have an an entity ID that shows
up in the knowledge base we definitely
want that to be unambiguous we want to
have for New York City we want to have
an unambiguous entity ID in our
knowledge base so there's no question
about which New York we're talking about
this the same is true for the relations
that we don't want the relations to be
ambiguous in any way okay let me keep
going we want to talk a little bit about
the approach to evaluation it's a really
good idea to define the way you're gonna
evaluate your systems before you start
building systems is kind of the same
idea as test-driven development in
software engineering so first you set up
a test harness that allows you to
measure performance and then you can
start building your system and iterating
on performance having that test harness
set up in advance means that you can
sort of measure progress as you go and
actually a great first step is to build
a random classifier that only takes five
minutes to write but gives you sort of a
baseline on which you can begin to
measure progress a good approach to
evaluation typically starts with
splitting the data into different pieces
and in this case I'm advocating a
three-way split into a tiny split a
train split and a dev split so the tiny
split is only 1% of your data it's gonna
be really small but it's also going to
be really fast to train and test on the
tiny split and the merit of having a
tiny split is that you can do your early
development on this tiny split and it
can help you like just sort of flush out
bugs in your code like just make sure
your code is running properly before you
scale up to training on the big test
train split and testing on the dev split
which can take a lot longer to run so I
think that's a great methodological
practice that I encourage you to use in
other places and then the Train split is
going to be about three quarters of our
data the dev split is going to be about
a quarter of our data that's a pretty
typical set up and during development
you'll typically train on the train
split and test on the dev split
there's also we've also held out a
test split that we're going to use for
the bake-off so you don't have access to
that yet but it exists and we're you
know keeping it in a vault deep
underground for now I'm gonna skip this
part there's some discussion of how to
split but we want to split both the
knowledge base and the corpus and
there's some discussion of how to try to
do that split so that those align well
with each other as as much as possible
but I'm gonna skip that for now then we
want to talk about evaluation metrics a
little bit so this is a we're factoring
our problem into 16 binary
classification tasks one for each
relation because it's binary
classification evaluation metrics are
pretty straightforward this is an arena
where it's sort of well understood what
the best evaluation metrics are
typically precision and recall are what
you look at particularly when there's an
unbalanced label distribution as there
is for this problem so we're going to
look at precision and recall but it can
be really helpful when developing a
system to have a single summary
statistic on which to hillclimb so to
combine precision and recall into one
statistic the most common solution is to
use F measure which is just a harmonic
mean of precision and recall usually
people use f1 which gives equal weight
to precision and recall for this
application though I think you can make
an argument that precision matters more
than recall the goal here is to identify
new KB triples that we can add to our
knowledge base and we don't want to be
putting garbage into our knowledge base
it's better to miss something than to
put garbage into our knowledge base so
we want to give more weight to precision
than we do to recall and the way to do
that is using the F 0.5 score which
gives a little bit counterintuitive but
gives twice as much weight to precision
than it does to recall and SK learn
makes it easy to calculate that we also
want to have a summary statistic that
averages across labels so we'll compute
precision recall and F zero point
for each relation separately but we want
to have a way to combine it all into one
summary statistic an average and the
only question is whether to do a micro
average or a macro average we're gonna
do a macro average which gives equal
weight to each relation because it's not
really significant it doesn't really
matter how many instances happen in this
data set to fall into each relation so
we're going to treat each relation as
equally important so there's some code
that helps you actually run these
evaluations we run it here on a random
classifier and what you see when running
on a random classifier is that precision
is bad almost everywhere which kind of
makes sense but recall is always right
around 50 percent this random classifier
is just flipping a coin it's predicting
true half the time so it kind of makes
sense that if there actually is a true
label when the label is actually true we
have about a 50/50 chance of getting
that and that's what recall is measuring
but we're saying true all the time and
most of the time that's not the right
label which is why precision is quite
low so the macro average precision is 8%
the macro average recall is 51% the
macro average f score is 10% it's really
low it's much closer to the precision
than it is to the recall which is a
characteristic of F measure it tends to
be pessimistic much closer to the lower
of precision or recall and then the next
thing I do is create a simple baseline
model which I'll let you look at it on
your own but the basic idea with a
simple baseline model it's not even a
learned model it's not it's not a
machine learned model instead all we do
is look through the examples of tied to
each relation and we find the most
common phrase that occurs between the
two entity mentions we count up what are
the three most common phrases for each
relation and then we just use exact
matches to one of those three phrases as
the predictor so we find for example
that for the there was a it was a
particularly good one was it
parents yeah so look at the parents
relation for the parents relation the
most common phrases are comma son of and
and comma in the forward direction and
in the reverse direction and comma and
and his son so you can like those sort
of make sense certainly seeing the word
son in there makes sense you also see
that punctuation and stop words are
really common so it's probably a bad
idea
to drop those and some other NLP tasks
people advocate dropping stop words and
punctuation you probably don't want to
do that here you also see see the comma
by itself a bear comma shows up almost
everywhere almost every one of these
relations has comma as one of its most
frequent middles
so comma is significant but it's
extremely ambiguous it could indicate
almost any relation we can evaluate how
this does and it does significantly
better
the summary statistic is eleven point
five so that's the macro averaged F
score significantly better than the
Ranma guesser but on the other hand
still really terrible right the random
guesser was like nine percent now we're
up to eleven and a half percent it
definitely helped but it's still really
terrible and actually you should have
modest expectations for how we're going
to be able to do on this task on this
data set we're gonna have trouble
getting great precision because the KB
is incomplete there could be some
relational triples that actually are
true in real life and there are
sentences in the corpus that tell us
that they're true but we can't measure
that they're true because they're not in
the KB that's the KB being incomplete
and we're also gonna have trouble
getting great recall because there could
be some relations that are true and are
in the KB but there's no evidence of
in the corpus both the KB and the corpus
are kind of small and that's gonna put
limits on how good the precision and
recall we can achieve will be
nevertheless the next step in this
journey is to apply a real machine
learning model to this problem and in
the second notebook which is linked from
the from the course web page you'll see
an example of doing that so using a bag
of words feature representation logistic
regression classifier the most vanilla
setup possible and even that very
vanilla set up gets to a summary
statistic of if I remember 55% which is
vastly better than this simple baseline
model so that will start you down the
road that vanilla setup leaves lots of
room for improvement and one of the
things you'll be looking at in homework
3 and in the bake-off is how to do much
better on that alright thank you